one of the most gratifying dimensions of
a day like this is being able to
recognize those alumni leaders who
volunteer their time and talent in this
case we have an opportunity to salute
six alumni who have dedicated more than
a decade of service to Columbia and at
this point much more because these are
people who've been recognized with the
Columbia metal before but now there is a
newly designed metal and we're going to
present that to them so they will be
some of the few people on the planet who
have two versions of the Columbia metal
so I would like to invite to the stage
Donna McPhee vice president for alumni
affairs and president of the columbia
alumni association who's been behind the
scenes all day is telling me she's not
going to talk but I hope you'll go up to
her at the reception afterwards she is a
powerhouse and Fred Van Sickle executive
vice president for university
development alumni relations who you met
earlier they are coming up to help us
present the metals with the highest
honor bestowed by the University on an
alum with gratitude for service and
volunteer work so I think everybody is
here yes okay first I'd like to ask
Kenneth S carpenter 1950 Columbia School
of Social Work to please come to the
stage he was originally awarded the
medal in 1976 lives in Washington DC and
is now receiving the newly designed
metal I don't think I've seen it
actually oh my alma mater is on the
matter
and we're going to do the photo you know
this is the Academy Awards we're not
going backstage but we're doing the
photo right here no no you just you want
him over there okay wherever you dude I
should have saved my Columbia spectator
comments you know my little factoids for
right now to sort of fill in the blanks
congratulations all right next Stephen
are Kleinberg Stephen are Kleinberg is
1963 Columbia College he received the
medal originally in two thousand lives
in st. Michael's Maryland it's beautiful
out there I think you should have an
alumni event and we're in the water I'm
sorry I'm fighting myself there
congratulations
we're going to get a lovely group shot
in the end robert h La Fleur 1968
Columbia Law School i originally
received the metal in 2001 lives in
washington DC and welcome mr. Loffler
did I say that correctly Loffler know so
what's the scoop him tell me loeffler
laughs loeffler okay i knew i was going
to miss one up even though the ca people
wrote it down for me Robert Leffler
congratulations Louis J Mendelsohn 1955
Columbia College 1958 Columbia Law
School originally awarded the medal in
1991 lives in Bethesda Maryland my
neighbor I live in Chevy Chase TC close
congratulations Roy are Russo 1956
Columbia College originally awarded the
medal in 1994 lives in springfield
virginia congratulations
and finally Jessie p smith Columbia
School of Social Work 1945 originally
awarded the medal in 1982 lives in
Washington DC now I'm going to get out
of the way so we can get a great picture
and just reminds you that we're having a
reception right afterwards I thank you
so much for coming thank you so much for
supporting Columbia and we look forward
to seeing you again the next time thank